we are going to look at the countdown
numbers game so i used to teach
uh programming and i used to teach the
countdown letters game
uh and that worked out quite well i
always liked teaching to the to the
problem not at all so it was quite nice
to have that focus of the countdown
latest game
and i was always thinking next year i'll
do the numbers game because i'll be able
to work that out and find a solution to
that
and over the years i didn't really find
one
so what i ended up doing was brute
forcing
the entirety of the countdown numbers
game so i've simulated every single
possible game that can ever happen
within
countdown numbers
countdown is a television show
focused around the letters game
predominantly but you have the numbers
game as well
and what you have to do is you have to
pick six numbers
and with those numbers you have to
achieve a target score by adding
multiplying
dividing and subtracting it's got to be
a three-digit number so between 100 and
[Music]
so they actually pick they pick big and
small numbers so big numbers are 25
50 75 and 100 and small numbers are 1 to
and they pick two big numbers and four
small ones
and then you have your six numbers and
then you have to go and make a target
number with those
one big number okay we'll give you a
hundred
um the rest small
should we one two four
five and seven we're gonna make a target
unless i think
go on well i'll pick a number off my
screen right now the
duration remaining on one of my memory
cards is two two six
two two six so you've got to make 226
using these numbers
i can see that straight away 2 times 100
yep and then you've got the 6 is the one
and the seven
yep and then you've got four times five
is 20 right
yeah you've solved it you've done it
there so yes
this is the basic crux of the game so
some things we can do and some things we
can't do
we can't concatenate numbers so we can't
put two and four together and make 24.
we can't ever go into negative numbers
and we can never use decimals
uh and one more thing to say the
solution doesn't have to use all the
numbers i think you used
do you use all of them you don't have to
yeah and i decided to brute force this
which seems
i think a little bit less difficult than
it actually was so we hopefully have
some interesting statistics at the end
of this
but um so what the goal of what we have
to do is we have to mix up
every single possible number every
single
permutation that can happen with every
sin single symbol that that can happen
to so plus minus multiply and divide
which
results in a lot of numbers so we've got
some of them here so assuming we have
just six random numbers and then what we
need to do
is we need to find a way of putting add
minus subtract and divide
in here we're going to also need to use
five symbols okay so we'll just tack
these on at the end so plus
minus multiply plus
and divide okay we need to find a way of
combining these in
every single possible combination so i
tried many ways of doing this
because if you have for example a sum
like this
this can be interpreted in many
different ways so for example if we put
brackets
here that means we do this operation
first that means we do five minus three
which is two minus two which equals zero
if we have the same sum and we put the
brackets here
we'll do three minus two first which
equals one and then subtract that away
from five which equals four
so we need a way of representing which
way we need to go about doing this
ultimately when i was programming this i
had to solve this problem and make sure
things were interpreted in the correct
way
so what we did is we did we used
something called reverse polish notation
which luckily you've got a couple of
videos on rpn
reverse polish notation it saves the
interpreter or the compiler
an awful lot of effort so just give you
an example of how this works
which is quite good when it comes to how
i've written this
at the top this equation here so 5 minus
3 in brackets minus 2 0
would be written as 5
3 minus 2 minus
the second equation is written as
5 3 2
minus minus so the actual order
of where the symbols come up denotes how
the equation is going to be handled
once this was solved it means we didn't
have to deal with brackets because i did
try dealing with brackets and that was
just a nightmare
this means what we can do is we can
actually have our six numbers here
and five either five symbols of which
what we're going to do with it plus
minus
all of that and then what we can do is
we can just shuffle them
go through every single permutation of
this list
even what you've written there looks
like quite a daunting
prospect it is daunting it's daunting
because you've also this isn't all of
the combinations of symbols you can use
either
so we've got to deal with that as well
now there are 11 things here
so in order to shuffle these it would be
11 factorial which is close to 39
million but we've got an issue here
because we're only using this
these symbols and there are lots of
possible symbols we could use in here
and what i found was there's actually 54
sets of different symbols we use if we
only care about
the count of each symbol as in how many
there are in the set we don't care about
the order because everything's being
shuffled anyway there were 54 individual
sets of these that we could get
so when you say that you mean it might
be plus plus plus minus minus it might
be
plus yep exactly and we've got to
because we're brute forcing the entire
countdown so we want to find
every single way it can get every single
number the amount of possible
combinations we can have
is 11 factorial times 54. 11 factorial
is 39 million
54 i think i've got it written down here
is
it's 2.155 billion
so you're thinking this is quite big and
then we have another issue
this is only one set of board numbers
we've got here so there
are 1300 243 boards
so it's actually 2.155 billion times
1300 243 which is a lot this took a long
time so on my home pc to do
one of these one set of numbers took
about two and a half hours
two and a half hours times thirteen
hundred to forty three
is a long time so we ran into some
issues here but we got it done so um
some things
helped we have the computer vision lab
in nottingham
who lent me their cluster for a little
bit that's the same cluster that did
hashcat with mike pound and also the
digital research team
without their help i wouldn't have
gotten this done in a reasonable time
frame
and i'm talking like over a year
probably of using two cores of my
computer
and that's just annoying and not
something i'm wanting to do so yes we
did it
and having done this and done every
single
possible countdown numbers um game that
can ever happen
we've got some statistics on some some
numbers
some good some bad and i can tell you
some things about them we can talk about
what the easiest and hardest target
numbers to make
so because we know um every single
possible countdown numbers game we can
work out
how many sets of board numbers could
solve every single target
so some will be harder than the other so
the
easiest number to make in countdown the
target number that most sets of board
numbers can make
that's available to them if they do the
right maths
i want to go crazy and say something
like 999 but no maybe 100 100.
exactly so yep it's 100 there are
actually four numbers that can
um that share the easiest
the easiest to make and they are 100 102
104 108. 13 240
of all possible boards can make these
numbers there's one absolutely useless
board
which is one one two two three three
which cannot make a number over 100
so not a single solution can be made
with that so if that ever comes up
you're in trouble and then we're getting
onto the hardest one so the hardest
number
um to make is the one that is possible
the one that could be solved by the
fewest number of boards is it a large
prime or something
it sounds like it i don't know if it's a
prime but i guess it might well be
yeah go and just have a guess
good enough um it's nine hundred and
nine hundred forty seven yep so 947 is
the hardest and that can only be
um that can only be made by 9017 boards
one thing i did deduce from this which i
think is probably quite obvious but i
did check
is that even numbers are much easier to
make than odd numbers and it's very
statistically significant
so if you get an even target number
you're very much more likely to be able
to solve that
which is something something nice to
know count out exists between numbers of
and 999 and for any given board numbers
we could be assigned any target number
in this range
if any at all how many sets of board
numbers do you think can make
every single number continuously on this
line
so it can make 100 100 203 all the way
up to 999
not very many 100. so when i did it i
wasn't sure if there'd be any
but there's actually 1226 of them
which is about 10 which is a lot more
than i thought
um is there a common factor is there
something you kind of need to have the
perfect you know like
a big number yeah so i think i don't i
don't have any exact stats on this
um but a big number definitely helps um
you can tell with the file sizes that
come up the
files are stored or the results are
stored as the
the board numbers and by looking at them
you can see that generally if you don't
have a big number
there's less there's less data in the
files so big numbers definitely help
with too many big numbers so
four big numbers becomes a bit of a
detriment so somewhere in between
there's a sweet spot i would imagine one
or two we needed
a lot of computational resources to do
this to solve this problem
and one of the things was was trying to
move it from my desktop computer to
a cluster so it could do more
computation so essentially the way my
program worked is it created a text file
which was the board numbers so six
numbers
dot text and then inside that it has
every single
um solution that can be made from those
six numbers that's generally how it
works
now when you're running one instance of
that program it's fine because
everything's just in a loop iterates
through
now if you want to split that problem up
there are probably some very nice ways
of doing it
but essentially what i did is um
i changed it so what it would do is it
would have a list of all the files it
knew it was going to generate because it
knew all the board numbers
and what it would do is it would look
inside the folder and if a file isn't
there
it would then start generating that file
and put a lock on it so that no one else
can
can go and do that file and if something
did try and access that file another
program accessed that file
it would say you can't use it so
something else is using it so what it
would do
one of the joys of that is once you've
got that program running
you can run it once and it will just
look for a file that isn't there
and then create it and start doing it
and if you ran another instance of the
program
it would just do the same thing and then
you can just start adding programs to it
until you get um i think i used 40 on
the cbl cluster
and then on the other cluster i was
allowed to use it got up to about
250 which is a lot so i wrote it all in
c
sharp yeah so i had to run it on linux
servers
so i used mono to do that which is an
open source compiler for c-sharp
nothing terribly complicated there were
lots of arrays lots of list manipulation
but everything was quite straightforward
the server's actually restarted a lot
because when you use external servers
what they can do is they um
you can pay for priority access or
non-projects if you don't pay priority
access sometimes they cut it off and say
you can have this back in 12 hours
someone else wants to use it which is a
bit of a pain so one thing i did do
when i was uh running the program is
what i was doing on my
desktop is whenever i found a solution
i'd write the text file immediately
but when i was using the cluster what i
do is when i was writing to a file
essentially i put everything that i was
going to write into a buffer
and i wouldn't flush it to write at the
very end so essentially the text files
it was generating were either empty
or finished and what that allowed you to
do is if you wanted to
um say for example if you were you were
taking up too much space in a cluster
and the admin
message you and says you're using a bit
too many uh a
bit too uh too much of resources that
you said you're going to
you need to clear some of it out what
you could do is you would know which
files haven't been written to yet
because they've got nothing in them so
you can just delete those files
close the close the processes that are
running those files
and you won't have any confusion there
because if it was writing
as it was going along what you'd find is
that some of the files would have data
in them some of them wouldn't
um and that was absolutely fine you
could of course do things like just
write a little tag at the end of the
file
to make sure that everything's
appropriately finished
i kept on not knowing how long this was
going to take so this has been scheduled
for a few times
i was just doing things quickly not
thoughtfully
so yeah it was a series of less
optimal solutions to many problems put
together
in a program which worked absolutely
fine in the end which is yeah
nice and this one
so these two have a little battle and
it's this one that wins
we've now got our two parents which we
will draw here
so they were an awful lot of effort in
actually
executing the expressions that you write
down
let's